it is not many days we get to see an
african-american woman standing at that
podium ringing the bell representing a
sports brand when we think jockstraps
who jerseys what does this mean to you
um this it's so incredible first of all
to be a woman and to be representing
Under Armour to be standing next to
Steph Curry and next to Jordans fee and
then to be here
I never imagined in a million years that
I would have an opportunity like this
and it's an honor it's a complete honor
that I'm feel like I'm being looked at
as a person as a human being not as a
woman well as an artist
and an athlete your brand is so
important to you you've been with Armour
for the last couple of years your first
campaign I will what I want was their
most successful there have been over
nine million views at this point when
you were deciding who isn't what is my
brand who I want to be why would you
think a sports brand like us you know
everything that I do is something that I
genuinely and truly feel inside is my
truth and what I stand for and
everything that Under Armour stands for
and stood for when I agreed to be a part
of it it represents me it's about being
a normal person and working hard at
whatever goal it is that you want to
succeed in it's about being an underdog
in succeeding having the will to make it
beyond what people say your limitations
are and that's what works for me and
Under Armour represents all of those
things so it just made sense it wasn't
about a sports fan or a male-driven
sports brand it was just that the
message worked for my message well we
know what you've done for the brand in
terms of awareness the amount of women
who now care about this brand what
you've done what is the brand done for
you as a dancer it's brought dance to a
much broader audience for athletes and
sports people sports fans to now look at
ballerinas and think okay that is that
does take a lot of work and they are
athlete
as well Under Armour has given me an
incredible platform to be seen by more
people than just the classical ballet
world and for them to understand how
much work and dedication and sacrifice
that it takes to do what I do
is that what this campaign is about when
I think Steph Curry Jordan speith misty
Copeland the rule yourself campaign
easily could have been about just
running a victory lap saying did it drop
the mic I just won but it doesn't seem
to be that the campaign is at all that's
that's why that's what separates Under
Armour from a lot of other sports brands
I think it's it's sending that message
that it's not about the destination it's
the journey and how how you get to that
place of success and that it's not you
know you just see someone
all of a sudden dunking a basketball but
what it takes to get there and we all
wake up every morning and have to work
our butts off to get to this point and
that's what this new ad is showing it's
showing all that it takes to make up a
person like me staffer Jordan and what
success what it takes to get there then
where are you in your journey
professionally I am just now starting I
feel like I'm starting over what in my
career I'm now at a point that I've
dreamed of being at as a principal
dancer and now it's like this is where
the journey begins as a principal dancer
and as as an artist as a real true
artist at a very high level and it's
exciting do you view yourself as an
artist or an athlete both there's
there's no way to separate those two
things as a ballerina we are physically
at such a high level but then we also
have to become characters and we have to
tell a story and that's what separates
us from athletes is that we have to be
top-notch actors and actresses on top of
being in the best physical condition in
that 0.02 whatever you know that
category so it's such a special thing to
be a part of does that mean you think
you're in better shape than Tom Brady
speed I think because we're using we're
using so many apps but aspects of
ourselves that it's not just a physical
thing and and it takes so much mental
preparation and being present mentally
to do what all of these athletes do ok
so get on mat a bit on top of it all you
know we have to be so just kind of
settled into things we can't show the
hard work we have to make it look
effortless we have to make it look like
we're just up there as an actor and
telling a story but what we're doing
physically is just as demanding so
there's just a lot more that goes into
it that way is perceived as a very elite
art form very high-end very exclusive
and UA is really about mass market and
underdog and inclusion so are you
changing what the narrative is for
ballet that's been my message is that I
don't come from the typical background
that most ballet dancers do to be a part
of this world and my message has always
been that every child should be able to
experience something like the classical
ballet world which has changed my life
it shouldn't matter where you come from
what you look like what your body type
is you should be able to every child to
be able to experience that and hopefully
that is changing the perception of
ballet and making people feel like they
can be a part of it they can come and
watch it and they don't have to look a
certain way to be a part of it so in
terms of ruling yourself willing
yourself to do things and achieve things
that you haven't yet what do you want to
do next hmm I want to continue to
educate people on the classical ballet
world for them to respect us in the same
way they respect athletes for them to
see us in that way especially as as
women that we should be equal to you
know these top athletic men that we
should be seen in the same in the same
light and not and not have to deal with
body shaming and not have to deal with
you know our physical appearance but our
performance and what we bring to
table do you feel like you've influenced
Under Armour as a brand in terms of
products we know what you've done in
terms of brand awareness the success the
campaign has had but in terms of what
they sell what they put on their shelves
what women like me walk in the store to
buy
how have you influenced them are there
product that I could say misty where's
this mist Yves the reason Under Armour
makes this well i more recently they've
started producing a leg warmer so i'd
like to think that i've been a part of
that influencing them with that but i
think as soon as a dancer you know as
long as we're wearing things that are
tight enough and supportive enough in a
rehearsal process then anyone can wear
that and so when i'm in the commercials
I'm wearing all Under Armour product and
I can move in it and it's stretchy and
flexible just like anyone who's doing
yoga or pilates so it works for a dancer
rule yourself kicked off thank you